In this session,
we're going to take up some of the mental illnesses that arise after a person
has been sentenced to death.
We've talked to in another session about competency for trial and issues of
insanity,
uh,
and so forth.
Now we're going to look about a Wa at whether a person is competent to appeal or
to basically drop their appeals,
uh,
and competent to be executed.
A supreme court has already decided that a person does not need to be competent
in order for their federal Habeas Corpus case to be litigated.
In the case of Ryan versus Gonzales decided in 2013,
uh,
the court said that a person who's in federal Habeas Corpus proceedings,
who may be incompetent and there were two cases,
one out of the Court of Appeals for the ninth circuit,
one out of the sixth circuit that had stayed the proceedings because the
petitioners in those cases were not competent.
But the court said that because a habeas corpus is a backward looking record
based,
uh,
the nature of it.
Uh,
therefore the person did not have to be competent.
The lawyers could do the research,
the writing and the briefing.
Uh,
district courts do have some discretion.
they can ask with regard to particular issues in a case,
would there be a substantial benefit,
uh,
from the petitioners assistance?
In other words,
the lawyer goes to the judge and says,
your honor,
I need to be able to talk to my client to have a rational conversation with my
client,
with him having some understanding of what's going on here,
uh,
to go forward.
Uh,
the court says you a district court can grant a stay there,
uh,
but that if it looks like it's going to take a long time,
then the court should not grant a stay,
uh,
out of,
allowing the state to go forward and carry out its judgment.
So here the practicalities,
uh,
say,
to at least the Supreme Court,
uh,
we're not going to stay in execution for a long period of time just because the
person is not competent,
uh,
to,
like competent for trial,
able to assist their client,
able to assist their lawyer,
uh,
enabled,
understand the proceedings that are going on.
Uh,
but there's another competency,
a question that comes up and that's whether or not a person can give up their
appeals.
That's a decision,
uh,
that a petitioner makes,
not unusual in some cases that petitioners decide at some point and usually
linked to mental illness,
uh,
that they want to give up their appeals.
And 1960,
uh,
the supreme court decided a wreath versus Peyton.
A Reese was a case in which the case went up to the court just on a question of
whether or not he could withdraw his petition for social ride of the Supreme
Court.
Uh,
the court sent it back and a very brief two or three paragraph opinion of
procuring them opinion that is by the court that said the district court was to
determine whether he had a capacity to appreciate his position and,
uh,
and to make a rational choice with regard to continuing or abandoning
litigation.
In other words,
was he suffering from a mental disease disorder or defect,
which would substantially affect,
and the words that are chosen,
her very important as we'll see,
substantially affect his capacity,
uh,
in the premises.
Uh,
so that's the question.
It's going to be raised.
Uh,
when a person says,
ah,
I want to give up my appeals.
Now,
one of these,
uh,
cases,
involved with whole name Ronald Gene,
uh,
Gene Simmons,
who committed a number of,
uh,
murders in the state of Arkansas.
Uh,
Ron Gene Simmons did not want to appeal his case.
And in fact,
he told his lawyers not to appeal and they abided by that another inmate a
Jonah's Whitmore came forward and said,
well,
I will represent a round gene Simmons and I have an interest in this because I'm
under a death sentence.
And the court compares,
uh,
cases and doing it.
The proportionality review,
uh,
I have an interest as a citizen,
in there being an automatic appeal.
Uh,
this is the only case I'm aware of where there was not a direct appeal to the
state Supreme Court after trial.
In most states,
in death penalty cases,
that's automatic.
But at this time,
it was not in Arkansas where the Arkansas Supreme Court turns a Whitmore down
and he goes to the United States Supreme Court and he loses on two grounds,
which help us understand,
uh,
what the court requires in these situations.
First,
uh,
the court said he is not injured,
the fact that he's another death row inmate and that his case might be compared,
uh,
with,
Simmons case is just simply too big a stretch and,
uh,
he has to be directly injured.
And this is critical for the court to have jurisdiction because this was whether
there was a case or controversy,
uh,
before the court that the person have to have some injury.
In fact,
just as Marshall pointed out in his dissenting opinion that the court did not
have to enforce that and could consider this because the importance of the
public issue of his that was rejected by the majority of the Supreme Court.
Secondly,
uh,
and this would defeat,
Whitmore right out of the,
out of the start.
Uh,
they said he couldn't be the next friend,
uh,
for Semans,
that an ex friend has to be someone who's very close,
uh,
to the defendant,
someone like a parent,
a spouse,
child,
uh,
someone who's got that person's best interest at heart and who's very close to
that person,
not just someone who,
uh,
I think the court in one case or referred to him as a,
a inner meddler,
uh,
who's coming along and trying to decide what to do.
One case that illustrates just how difficult and heart wrenching these decisions
can be is the case of Harvey and Rebecca Rumba who brought a wanting to stand in
as next friend for their son Charles.
Uh,
no question that they could be next friends.
They were his parents.
So the next friend question is not present.
The question present is could Charles make his own decision or as his parents
were pleading to the court,
they're saying our son is not able to decide things for himself and we should be
able to make the decision for him.
Uh,
Charles Rumba was 17.
At the time of the offense today,
he wouldn't be eligible for the death penalty,
but he was a bag at the time.
His case was before the court.
He was profoundly depressed.
Uh,
he suffered from schizophrenia,
paranoid schizophrenia.
Uh,
he had auditory hallucinations.
he was a self mutilate or he had tried to cut his arm off and he had talked and
an occasion about experiencing the pain of self mutilation and being cleansed by
it.
Uh,
he was suicidal.
He had attempted suicide several times.
And in fact,
during the hearing in Federal District Court,
he advanced upon the United States,
Marshall,
uh,
and the Marshall shot him in the courtroom,
and he goes off to the hospital and the hearing continues,
uh,
without him.
Charles wants to give up his appeals,
uh,
and be executed,
in large part because of his mental illness.
Uh,
and his parents are asking the court not to let him do that,
but to say that he lacks the capacity,
uh,
to make his own decisions and they should be able to decide for him a while.
The case centers very much on the testimony of Dr. Logan,
a doctor at the Springfield,
a federal hospital,
uh,
where run by had been sent for evaluation.
Uh,
and it shows how difficult,
uh,
it can be to determine if someone meets this danger,
the dusky standard of competence to make their own decisions.
In these cases,
uh,
the judge is asking,
the doctor here,
I what we're all trying to understand a is to what extent the depression was a
coercive force in the decision that Charles made to give up his appeals.
Dr. Logan said,
well,
if you weren't so depressed,
if he didn't have bouts of paranoia,
if he didn't have auditory hallucinations,
he probably would go forward with the litigation.
So obviously there's a very direct relationship between his depression,
his paranoia,
his solution,
nations,
and the fact that he wants to give up his appeals at this point.
Uh,
Dr. Logan says his mental problems,
it affect him.
This was the question asking Dusky does it affect his ability to make a
decision?
It affects them to the extent that if he were not so depressed,
if he did not have the periods of paranoia,
were his periods of auditory hallucination not present.
Uh,
and if he wasn't so hopeless about his position,
both his mental health condition and his hope of ever winning his appeal,
uh,
he might be able to better cope with spending time on death row,
and waiting and seeing how he,
his appeals turned out.
Uh,
but his mental condition would not permit him to do that.
He goes on to say that his mental condition influenced him to a certain degree,
maybe even to a substantial degree.
Uh,
he recognizes that his mental condition is deteriorating.
it's a realistic assessment.
It is deteriorating.
It influences him.
Uh,
he's been miserable for a long time and he's going to be miserable for a long
time and he understands that,
uh,
and he's able,
nevertheless,
he's able to think coherently.
So the judge,
he analogizes is to someone who has cancer that doesn't want any more treatment.
He's miserable because he has all these mental illnesses.
Uh,
he's going to get a,
it's going to continue to be miserable because there's very little prospect that
he's going to improve.
Uh,
in terms of his mental condition,
uh,
of course,
most people who are in prison who had this feeling of hopelessness because of
their depression and their schizophrenia and their self mutilation and so forth,
of course would not have,
uh,
the opportunity to have the state put them to death.
Uh,
only because Rumbas on death row is he able to have the state carry out his
execution,
uh,
in,
in his life,
uh,
the court as if he's able to understand what's going on.
No question.
He understands what's going on.
A court asks,
is his decision rational based on what he presently faces?
Now this is a court asking,
is the decision that Charles Rumbas making rational?
Well,
that's probably anyone could say the weather decisions rational or irrational
and probably reasonable people would disagree about that.
Uh,
but Dr. Logan says yes,
based on his past experience and based on what he presently faces,
I believe it's rational or logical at least.
So is the fact that it's logical for a person who has terminal cancer not
wanting treatment,
but this is of course,
is not treatment.
This is being executed.
Is it rational or logical for a person who's facing execution to decided life is
so miserable that they don't want to go on and therefore they want to give up
their appeals?
Uh,
the court employees three steps,
the majority,
this is a two to one decision of the United States Court of Appeals for the
fifth circuit.
One is the person suffering from a mental disease or defect.
If no,
you stopped right there.
But in Rumbas case,
there's no question he's suffering from all kinds.
He's depressed,
he's schizophrenia,
he's got a major mental illnesses that may substantially affect his decision.
So go to step two.
Step two,
does the mental disease or defect prevent him from understanding his position?
Again,
the answer,
here's no Rumbar,
uh,
understands his position,
has a good understanding both legally and factually a of where he stands in the
legal system.
We go to step three,
even if he understands his position,
does the mental illness.
And the judge asked the question,
now,
prevent him,
not does it influence him?
Now,
does it affect him?
But does it prevent him from making a rational choice among the options you
could state those last two questions as Reese did,
uh,
whether they substantially affect his understanding,
of his legal position,
uh,
and the choice that he has before it.
Uh,
at any rate,
uh,
Dr. Logan says there's no question.
The severe depression has some influence on his decision to give up his appeals.
He's capable of appreciating his position.
He understands where he is,
that he's in court with a Habeas Corpus petition and you can go forward.
I did not,
uh,
and,
that he can make a sufficiently and substantially rational choice with regard to
abandoning a further litigation.
In his case,
uh,
the court allows,
Charles to take over the case,
dismiss it,
and uh,
he's eventually executed.
Judge Goldberg.
Desena Judge Urban Goldberg says,
wait a minute.
Competency is a mixed question of law.
In fact,
that means the,
a blend of the facts as we have them in the record,
but also the law of competency.
And the court thinks that,
uh,
the,
excuse me just as Goldberg thinks that the court defers too much,
uh,
on,
on the,
on the question and doesn't,
uh,
analyze it enough itself.
Uh,
he says,
if you look at this carefully,
what rumble is doing is taking logical steps towards a goal that is the product
of his mental illness.
This is a question of a man giving up as appeals because he is mentally ill,
uh,
and he's unable to determine what's in his best interest.
Has Mental illness keeps him from deciding what's in his best interest?
What does a very close case,
a very disturbing case for the parents,
for everybody involved.
But it shows how difficult these decisions are.
Uh,
and deciding whether or not a person has the capacity that is the ability to
make their own decision,
uh,
or whether it's influenced,
by,
uh,
the mental illnesses.
Uh,
particularly if you have the profound and deep melanomas.
Is that somebody like Charles Rumble hat?
Uh,
but those are the questions of courts decide,
uh,
possibly different judges would have come out in a different way on this case.
Uh,
but as it turns out,
rumble loses his parents are not allowed to step in and represent him and he's
put it in the state of Texas,
puts him to death.
Uh,
we look at these terms that are critical in this analysis,
prevent product or effect.
Did the mental illness prevent him?
I would say the middle is he can't understand what's going on because of the
melanomas or is his decision a product?
Do we really know what the product of mental illness is?
Is the decision a product of the middle notice or does the mental illness
substantially affect his capacity to understand?
If you ask these questions differently,
you might get different answers.
Because with Rumba,
you might say,
uh,
that his bill illness does substantially affect his capacity.
Uh,
maybe not so much to understand,
but to make a rational and informed and intelligent decision,
uh,
with regard to giving up litigation are going forward.
Uh,
but it is the sort of parsing that the courts do in this very mysterious area of
mental health where very often there are different doctors giving different
diagnoses and different opinions about the abilities of people who suffer for
melanomas.
Well,
another place where men alone is often can come into play is with regard to the
execution of a person.
Uh,
many people,
uh,
on death row,
may have already had mental issues in their case at trial.
Uh,
but some people will deteriorate,
uh,
significantly over the time period that they're on death row.
It's not a healthy place to be.
Uh,
and they may be in virtual solitary confinement during much of that time.
And so the date of the execution approaches,
the cases had been decided,
uh,
and it becomes a parent,
that this person doesn't understand what's going on,
that they're in a whole different world of reality,
uh,
in which they either don't know they're going to be executed or they don't
understand what execution is.
We looked earlier at a case out of Arkansas,
Ricky ray rector,
uh,
who after he was executed,
they go back to rectors.
Sal and find that he's put his Pi aside.
Uh,
he thinks he's going to come back after the execution and have dessert.
So he obviously had very little understanding of what an execution was in the
finality of the execution or what death was a,
but of course,
that evidence didn't come out until after the course had already held that he
was competent to be executed.
So we'll look at a couple of cases,
uh,
where the supreme court has dealt with this one Ford versus Wainwright where the
court first deals with both the procedures required and with the definition.
Uh,
and then after that,
Scott Pineta his case,
uh,
out of Texas,
um,
Alvin Ford versus Wainwright,
uh,
was the first case to present to the Supreme Court.
This question of,
uh,
whether or not a person was competent to be executed.
It was an open question if that time,
whether the Constitution prohibited the execution,
uh,
of a person who was,
insane as it was put forward.
In that particular case,
uh,
the court canvas,
what had been the practice in jurisdictions in the United States,
different states,
England,
and came to the conclusion that there was a constitutional prohibition to
executing someone who was insane.
But we're going to see the devil is in the definition,
uh,
in terms of how we describe that.
But the other issue that Ford had,
uh,
was he was claiming that the way in which it had been done,
the way in which he was determined to be competent,
uh,
did not measure up to due process standards.
Uh,
Alvin Ford was a person who,
uh,
was clearly suffering from delusions,
both in his speech patterns and what he believed.
His lawyers really couldn't talk to him,
uh,
because,
he didn't speak a of coherent,
uh,
English,
when he was talking to people.
Um,
and,
uh,
so the state since some doctors down,
examine him,
uh,
they won't take any information from Ford's lawyers about what his mental
condition is.
And it goes to the governor,
uh,
and a determination is made there within the executive branch,
that he's competent.
And Bob Graham,
the governor of Florida,
signs a warrant to put him to death.
A supreme court says,
you gotta do better than that.
Uh,
first of all,
the person who's about to be executed,
that person,
their lawyer has to be involved in this process.
If they've had a mental examination and want to put that before the fact finder
to determine,
uh,
whether he's competent,
they have a right to do that.
If they have lay witnesses to testify,
uh,
court didn't say that,
but,
uh,
the,
they,
they have a right to do that as well.
People who've watched this person and who've talked to this person,
and I have some sense of what this person's understanding is.
Uh,
if the prosecution is going to put forward evidence,
uh,
perhaps it's subject to cross examination as in most kinds of cases where
decisions are being made and finally the decision maker has to be more
objective.
It can't just be somebody in the governor's office.
Uh,
so as a result,
we find that the way in which Ford was determined to be competent,
uh,
did not meet constitutional standards.
I mean,
this is as basic as the case of Goldberg versus Kelly,
which talks about what kind of procedures a person's entitled to before their
welfare benefits are terminated.
Uh,
here we're talking about a much more serious decision.
Not that that isn't it a serious decision for many people,
but whether or not Alan Ford's life is going to be taken.
But then the question is,
what does it mean to be insane?
Uh,
Justice Marshall doesn't write much about that in his opinion,
which was for four members of the court.
Justice Powell cast the fifth and deciding vote.
Uh,
and in his opinion,
he says the eighth amendment forbids the execution of those who are unaware of
the punishment they're about to suffer and why they are to suffer it.
Uh,
the American bar association has suggested a slightly different standard one,
uh,
that the person understands why they were tried,
what the proceedings were and the reason for their punishment.
That's not much different than what a Justice Powell said.
Uh,
but secondly,
uh,
that the person lacks capacity to understand,
what's going on and to be able to communicate with their lawyers about what
might make unlawful or I'm just their execution.
It seemed pretty clear that after Ryan versus Gonzales,
uh,
that does not necessarily required since the court.
Although this may be a case where,
uh,
the person's,
cooperation is critical.
But of course,
the whole issue is competency itself,
uh,
with regard to deciding that some states have adopted the American Bar
Association's,
uh,
test.
Uh,
but for our purposes,
we'll look at what justice Powell said.
Uh,
the person has to be aware of the purpose of the punishment,
uh,
and then why they are receiving.
I am going to be put to death because I was convicted of murder in this court
many years ago.
Whatever rudimentary understanding the person has of it.
And so many people can be profoundly mentally ill,
it's proven to be,
can be profoundly out of touch with reality,
uh,
and still be found competent,
for execution.
One case that illustrates this is the case of Scott Panetta,
who was sentenced to death in Texas.
Uh,
pinetrees mental health problems were obvious from the outset.
he tried his case and a cowboy suit,
uh,
like a little boy would wear.
Uh,
he was found competent for trial,
allowed to try his own case instead of having a lawyer try the case.
Uh,
people that watch the trial said that those who were there were afraid of him,
were worried about what he was going to do.
Uh,
he clearly was not a functioning as a normal person during his trial.
and his mental health didn't get any better.
Uh,
during the time he was on death row.
by the time Texas was about to execute it,
a Scott Bennett,
he was suffering from a genuine delusion and according to the court,
uh,
that his execution was part of spiritual warfare between the demons and the
forces of darkness on one side and God and angels and the Forces of light on the
other side,
and that he was going to be executed,
uh,
to keep him from preaching.
Uh,
and that was basically his understanding.
In other words,
he did not understand that he was going to be executed for punishment for the
crime he committed.
He understood what execution was,
but the purpose he saw it being as to keep him from preaching,
uh,
not as punishment for the crime that he committed a supreme court in the
decision,
uh,
by,
Justice Kennedy,
uh,
says that,
the lower court should not have left out,
not considered a this delusional belief.
He also found that the procedures leading to the finding of competency in
Penedes case where we're totally inadequate by the Texas courts,
but we'll talk about what he said,
uh,
with regard to pinetrees competency.
Uh,
the argument that panettone suffered from a severe documented mental illness,
uh,
and had gross delusions preventing him from comprehending what was going on and
the purpose of the execution had to be considered in the lower court had not
done that.
So the case,
the court reversed the case,
uh,
send it back.
The fifth circuit in turn sent the case back.
The court of Appeals for the fifth circuit sent the case back to the District
Court judge them Starks.
Uh,
had a hearing,
once again found in Scott Perinetti was competent to be executed,
that he had a sufficient understanding,
uh,
of,
what execution was and what the purpose of it was as well.
Uh,
this standard,
uh,
does not keep profoundly mentally ill people from being executed.
Uh,
John Ferguson,
uh,
was executed in 2013,
by the state of Florida.
A Ferguson had an unusual belief system.
He believed that he was the prince of God and that after execution,
uh,
he would be resurrected and he would return to earth in that capacity.
Uh,
here,
there were many aspects of his mental illness,
but with regard to that delusion,
uh,
here's what judge Ed Karnes said for the 11th circuit that,
that thought about what happens after death might seem extreme to some people,
but he pointed out that every world religion from Christianity to z,
uh,
the believed in some kind of continuation of life after death.
Uh,
and,
uh,
some kind of resurrection.
Uh,
so,
uh,
Ferguson's belief that he's going to be resurrected,
the court said is not in that,
it's not all that different from the views of millions of Americans with regard
to their religious beliefs,
uh,
decisions almost self parity,
in terms of treating a profound mill illness is nothing but an unusual religious
belief.
Uh,
John Ferguson was executed by Florida on August 5th,
2013 and his case tells us a lot,
uh,
about the mental condition that a person can be in a and still be executed in
the United States.
It's.